hi there steve kaufman here hi all you
language learners remember if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe to my
channel
today i want to talk about something
that many of you are probably aware of
but i want to kind of share my views on
this the influence of the internet on
language learning and how it has already
dramatically changed language learning
and how it's going to continue to change
language learning and what triggered
this was an exchange on my blog the
linguist language
where i mentioned the fact that um in
universities i was told by the head of a
language department here at the
university of british columbia in
vancouver that there's a very
rapid drop-off in students
who enroll in in particular in difficult
languages
that after one or two years they uh you
know the enrollment drops to a fraction
of what it was for the first two years
so by the third or fourth year there are
very few people in language class which
presents a real problem for universities
it's difficult for them to justify these
classes and so forth and so on
and i said that maybe and then i also
pointed out the fact that in these
difficult languages in many cases for
example in russian even in ivy league
schools in the third or fourth year they
are reading russian literature in
translation not in the original
and so i suggested maybe the focus
should be on comprehension rather than
trying to produce the language which
doesn't seem to do much good for most of
the students anyway so someone said well
yeah but if you push people to read
literature they're going to be even less
interested and of course that is true
and and i think this gets back to one of
krashen's points and that is successful
language learning relies on compelling
input and if you force students to read
you know the canons of russian
literature dostoyevsky or whatever it
might be that's fine if the student is
interested in dostoevsky but if the
student is not interested then that's
actually counterproductive
so then i thought to myself well in
today's day and age
really why would we force the students
to learn or to read specific
content matter
uh
so i looked at what the internet offers
today first of all there's a tremendous
range of content it used to be if you
went to a language class the teacher was
the only source
of
information on how the language works
the only source of potential reading
material or listening material whereas
today any successful language learner
has to be searching for these things
himself or herself
so
i would see i mean if i look here you
know i've got my uh computer my macbook
i've got my little ipod nano
and i've got my ipad and of course i'm
using my iphone which i also use for
language learning but i'm using it to
film the uh the video so these are the
tools that we have so uh
you know if we had a language class
based on how the internet
makes things more accessible to everyone
where the teacher is no longer the
source of wisdom and content but simply
a guide
so if i were running a class i would say
let's say whatever the language is i
would say
initially day one here are some of the
issues in the language in japanese they
have these particles whatever they are
called you know
so these are some of the issues you're
going to encounter in the language or if
it's a if it's a romance language that
the verbs change for person for tense uh
and so forth and so on
and so then i would say now here's a
list of beginner material that you can
read and listen to and i would quite
frankly direct them to link because
there they can look the words up and
they can say phrases
go off and struggle through these and
then we'll come back into class
and
you bring in the phrases which they can
save and we'll go over some of the
phrases so i explained in general terms
what to expect in the language they then
go to discover the language find that
they can't understand and even if they
look up the words they can't make sense
of it so we discuss some of these
phrases in class and then send them back
to do more
reading and listening so this is sort of
in the initial period where the content
they would use would
basically be limited to short easy
material and then at a later stage
i would encourage students to go and
find whatever is of interest to them and
suggest here are some potential sources
so if you're interested in history and
politics and music and art in literature
whatever it is go off and find it and
then you know i would incur we can go
over certain aspects of the grammar in
class but of course these things don't
necessarily stick and so then i would
encourage people if you want to know how
to conjugate a certain verb if you want
to
get some more background on the use of
particles in japanese
google for it and then if you have any
questions bring them to class so that
the teacher would be
encouraging the students to find
information about the language wherever
they can find it and we can discuss it
in class encouraging to find content of
interest and then read and listen to it
on your own and bring phrases that cause
you difficulty to class
and and rather than having everyone read
aloud in class oh and i would even
encourage them to say all right in the
classroom there's 20 of us so we can't
all be speaking together sign up at
italki or at link or wherever you want
and get on with a native speaker and
then because the the tutor
typically provides a list of phrases
that cause you difficulty in the
conversation bring those to class and
we'll discuss them and if there are uh
patterns in the language that cause
difficulty for learner a typically they
also cause difficulty for other learners
so these can be discussed in the
classroom so i i mean that's just a very
quick sketch of a subject that needs to
be researched but surely the fact that
there is so much help available online
help in terms of online native speakers
help in terms of interesting content
help in terms of explanations of the
grammar and so forth and so on that the
role of the teacher as the sort of
source of all wisdom about the language
is
obsolete
and so uh getting back to my discussion
at my blog this commenter said you know
how can you have a situation where
people read what they want
doesn't everyone have to be reading the
same book in the classroom well that's
the way it's been up until now but i can
foresee a situation where people bring
whatever they've been reading to class
whatever problems they've been reading
the class and this becomes a subject of
discussion in the classroom initially
using
the language of the learner and
gradually moving into
more and more using the target language
so that's just to kind of get a
discussion going on how the internet has
changed language learning and i look
forward to your comments bye for now
you